This right over here is a, I guess you could say it's a
Side view of a human brain and I probably don't have to tell you that the brain is a
fascinating organ
It's what makes you you and me me everything that you are I
Think about, that
we're doing, we're seeing it's really all occurring in the brain. Even this
reality that you see around you, that you think is external to your brain. It's really a
simulation that your brain constructs for itself based on sensory input from the outside world, and so you could imagine is this incredibly
complex and you could even say
mysterious organ. And even though we don't understand everything about how the human brain works and I could imagine we will be exploring
how the brain works and learning more about it for decades if not centuries
to come there are things that we do know about the human brain.
We do know for example that it's made of it's made up of the estimates
I've seen of anywhere, or is roughly 80 to 100
billion -- let me write that in caps
billion
billion neurons and neurons are
the cells that
essentially do all of the
processing of our brain so this right over here is a is a if you were to kind of really
zoom in on the brain on a very, very small level. This right over here is a
blow-up of what a neuron looks like. There are other Khan Academy videos that go in much more depth on the anatomy of a neuron
and the functions of a neuron, but you see here that you have a you you have
it's a cell with a nucleus
just like other cells and what it does is essentially it receives input it receives signals from other neurons
and then when it's stimulated accordingly
it'll send signals to other neurons and this
stimulation and inhibition and sending signals from one neuron to another and through kind of chemic
chemoelectrical signals this is the stuff of our thoughts. Our thoughts are these these continuous
stimulations and inhibitions from one neuron to
another from one neuron to another neuron
It's not you know when when you're thinking a thought or you're looking at a dog or you're trying to solve an algebra problem,
it's not just one or two neurons that are firing; we're talking on the order of of
thousands or millions or maybe even billions of neurons firing and you have kind of these
impulses that are traveling through your brain depending on the connections that you're forming, the associations that you're
forming in the concept that you're looking at and these connections usually I'd say hey 80 to 100 billion
that's a huge number that's on the order of the number of stars in a Milky Way sized galaxy. That's an
unimaginably large number but to kind of blow your mind even more in the human brain in the human brain
there are
approximately 100
trillion
trillion synapses
synapses, and another way to think about them is -- let me write synapses
synapses or another way to think about these are kind of the connections between
these hundred billion neurons or these 80 to 100 billion neurons
So you're thinking each neuron roughly has a thousand connections to other neurons so it's an incredibly incredibly complex thing
So one question that you might say it's okay. Well, how do neurons relate to something
like
intelligence? Your ability to solve a problem or to
reason through things and what we do know if you look at the animal kingdom
is that the amount of neurons and the level of connections between the neurons is a
reasonable indicator if you go from species to species for intelligence, so for example?
jellyfish
Have eight hundred
eight hundred neurons
while human beings have eighty to a hundred
billion neurons
That human beings are kind of at the at the top of the food chain at least when it comes to how many neurons there
Are and the number of synapses, etcetera, kind of go with that.
But what about within a species, is intelligence something
intelligence that is something that is fixed are you just kind of born with a certain number of neurons?
And a certain number of connections between them
Or is it or is it something that can somehow change over time because of the environment that you're in? And this is the interesting
thing and this is something that I am I'm always thinking about it, and it's fascinating and I always think about it whenever I'm
Alone I'm thinking about things around what I'm trying to tackle a new subject
Is that there's actually a lot of research here on the fact that you can change?
you can change the structures in your brain through training the structures in your brain, so you can change it, so
This is this is changeable
Changeable or maybe ourselves
You can change it can
you can
change your intelligence based on essentially training your brain. And
the analogy that you can have here and you know you could say it's a metaphor
But in some ways it's a very direct metaphor
We all know that you can train your muscles; that if you lift weights if you strain your muscles
that then your muscle kind of
Your body recognizes that it needs to be stronger in that part of your body
And it will build that part of bodies as more you strain it the more
You stress it you give it a little time for repair
And then your muscle will come back stronger
And what a lot of the researchers have found over the last few decades is this is also true of the brain. You
see it as a child develops. This is some imagery that I got from Mindset Works
this is a site run by Carol Dweck was one of the researchers who really thinks about how the
How when you struggle, and when you try to tackle things more how that affects your ability to actually process it
actually affects your intelligence and what this imagery right over here is this is a an image of a
Child's I guess you could say neuron density or the synapsel
and the word density at birth, and we see that as a child learns languages,
they explore the world around them, as they struggle as a persevere as they try to emulate those around them, their brain actually gets
denser the more that a child uses tries to kind of form connections
Struggle stresses their brain the connections between the neurons become more numerous you see that here and they can also become
stronger so you might you actually might have a a once again more connections form and
They can become more active and when you think about the brain as you know when you have a thought
It's all of these associations between these different neurons
and they're all firing and stimulating each other what when you build those new connections is those new
Associations and a lot or those those new synapses it allows you to form new communication in your brain you new associations
It'll essentially allow you to think faster and better and to reason in ways that you couldn't have done before
And you might say okay?
Well that just happens from you know child to birth
but what about later on in life is this something that I can change now if I'm
10 years old or 20 years old or 50 years old and all the research says. Yes
You absolutely can and the key is how do you stimulate?
your brain just as someone of any age can stimulate their body and
Allow their muscles to grow by lifting weights by stressing them
There's been there been many studies that have shown it for example in animals that if you have an animal living in an unstated
Environment you actually don't have that many connections form you don't have that much much
Density of the Brain especially the synapse density but but then if you have an animal that's in a stimulating environment an environment that's constantly
challenging an environment where it's interacting with each others, and it's solving problems, then you actually have a higher density of of
Neural connections you have you essentially the animal has become smarter so what I find really interesting about this and I always
Remembered in my brain is it's very easy. You know a lot of us it's it's tempting to say okay?
I got what I got that's what my brain is and you know I'll just have to deal with it
But what all the research tells us is that is not the case the more you?
Stimulate the brain the more you struggle the more you kind of try to tackle new things you can actually train
Train yourself. Let me see if you can actually train yourself to
Be to be smart or whether you're smart or not smart is not something that you were just born with you can actually train yourself
And the best way to train yourself and this it's it's very analogous
and there's a lot of research is very similar to the way that you would train if you're lifting weights if you're lifting weights if
You can lift five
Pounds a lot you're not just gonna keep lifting five pounds you want to push yourself you want to try lifting with without you know
Consult your doctor or your trainer
You don't want to blow out your back or anything
But you want to keep lifting heavier and heavier weights and essentially making your muscle fatigue making your muscles struggle
It's not always an easy thing, but it pays off and the when you train your brain
It's essentially the same thing you want to tackle new problems
You don't want to tackle problems that are easy
But that's just like lifting the two-pound weight
over and over again you want to lift the 10-pound weight the 20-pound weight to eventually get to the
100-pound weight and so that means tackling problems doing problems that are going to be difficult. Where you you might make a mistake
But making that mistake is just like you know this picture of arnold where maybe he's not able to lift this weight
But then as his mom as his body kind of adjusts
It won't take too much time before he is able to lift that
to lift that weight so the important Takeaway is you you can completely change your intelligence by
Challenging yourself by putting yourself in a stimulating environment and your brain really is like a muscle
The more you train it the more you struggle. The more you stimulate it the smarter you'll get